[Music]
the race to restore power to hundreds of
thousands of quebecers on this Friday
night we're cold but we're not Frozen
when the job could be finished and the
obstacles crews are facing
honoring the life of Linda beardy the
March for a Manitoba woman and the calls
for justice for all missing and murdered
indigenous people
new scam alert what to watch for as
fraudsters prey on food Shoppers about
the size of the Saint Bernard dog the
discovery of dire wolves who once roamed
what is now Canada
[Music]
thank you
global national
foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the ongoing
efforts to restore power for hundreds of
thousands of people in central Canada
many preparing to spend a second night
in the dark after Wednesday's ice storm
downed trees and power lines across
large swaths of the region
Quebec is the hardest hit with workers
still scrambling to get electricity back
up and running the premier was Southwest
of Montreal today touring one of the
hardest hit regions as he stressed the
need for patients from quebecers this
long weekend
it will still need some time in order to
make sure that everybody has electricity
the Target right now is that tonight we
should have 80 percent of the people
back with electricity and tomorrow night
95 percent
tens of thousands are also without power
in parts of Ontario tonight and with
fears of lingering weather affecting
Cleanup in both provinces some are being
told to prepare to be in the dark until
early next week Mike Armstrong has
tonight's top story
progress at the peak more than 1.1
million homes were without power in
Quebec that number has now been cut by
more than half audrico back has added
Cruz it says it has almost 1400 repair
workers in the field a very welcome site
for people who've been without power and
heat for two days and counting at least
it's not January it's April we're not
we're cold but we're not frozen
now Crews have to check lines before
reconnecting neighborhoods when they do
that they tend to find new problems
right at very top of the tree this man
had a large Branch across the main wires
behind his house it was taken down by
Hydro Crews but the burn marks are still
there from the light show it put on
Wednesday it fell flat onto the three
wires caused a short circuit like you
wouldn't believe there was like
fireworks bang bang bang
Hydro Quebec officials say the work is
being Complicated by wind some trees
damaged by Ice are falling now from
strong gusts the new goal is to get down
to about 300 000 homes without power by
midnight and then work through the
weekend but it's clear because of the
scale of the problem for many this will
drag on the last to be reconnected could
be done as they said on the Sunday or
Monday search for Power is making the
malls that are open popular spots people
are plugging in anywhere they can the
other searches for gas many stations are
closed this one reopened Friday and it's
now running off a generator the line
stretched down the road and kept growing
waited roughly an hour but now if you
look it's about two to three hours
so yeah I guess we need gas now there
has been a second death in Quebec after
a man was killed Thursday by a falling
Branch Friday it was a man overcome by
fumes he was apparently operating a
generator in his garage it was found
unconscious by his wife the premier is
reminding people not to use things like
barbecues and generators inside ethu
Mike Armstrong in Montreal thanks as
Mike mentioned strong winds are
complicating some restoration efforts in
the region which could keep people in
the dark further into the long weekend
Global News meteorologist Anthony
Farnell joins us now Anthony what can we
expect in the coming days well need to
the good news is the winds are
diminishing and they'll continue to do
so through the night tonight and for the
next couple of days as high pressure
moves in Arctic high from the north of
Canada the bad news is with that high
and lighter winds tonight the
temperature is going to drop well below
freezing and if you haven't had power
now going on a third night in a row your
home is going to be awfully cold by
Saturday morning those winds today are
causing so many problems for the crews
trying to remove trees and branches from
the power lines 50 to 70 kilometers per
hour as I mentioned they're diminishing
but the temperature is also diminishing
minus five for a low in Montreal
Ottawa also hard hit minus seven so a
cold start to your Saturday but things
are getting better it's going to warm up
by afternoon about five degrees in
Montreal we could be close to 20 by
early next week there 13 in Calgary 15
in Edmonton it is a busy weekend with
Easter Ramadan Passover so everybody's
going to be out and enjoying the spring
conditions next week even milder across
most of the country the exception
BC still cool and wet at least for the
first half of next week
me too
Global News meteorologist Anthony
Farnell thanks
in Winnipeg a March is being held to
honor the life of an indigenous woman
found dead in a landfill this week
investigators say Linda beardy was not
murdered but her family is pushing for
police to do more Global's Rosanna
Hempel is following the story for us
tonight Rosanna
me through hundreds are gathered here at
the busy intersection of Portage and
Maine in downtown Winnipeg uh they're
chanting we are not trashed we are loved
with our signs no more Stolen Sisters
calling for justice for Linda Mary
beardy and all the missing and murdered
indigenous women and girls and
two-spirit people organizers are calling
for action and support for beardy's
family who said in a statement on
Thursday that they're saddened that
Winnipeg police chief Danny Smythe said
they're no longer investigating her
death as a homicide
right now there is no evidence to
support homicide
and as I say investigators remain open
to follow up on any other tips or
information that comes in beardy's body
was discovered at a landfill outside
Winnipeg on Monday initially police
ruled her death suspicious but on
Thursday Smythe announced they'd found
video surveillance showing the 33 year
old mother of four climbing into a
commercial garbage bin Monday morning
Smythe said a garbage truck had come by
the site a few hours later and had taken
its contents to the landfill so an
autopsy was conducted on April 4th and
it confirmed that the injuries that the
body sustained were consistent with that
of a truck handling of the bin you've
all seen how trucks empty the bins there
were no other injuries that suggest any
kind of Foul Play but in that statement
issued after the police news conference
beardy's family demanded more saying a
more fulsome investigation must take
place they say they felt intimidated by
officers and that they weren't treated
respectfully beardy's family is calling
on the federal government to appoint an
independent investigator to look into
her death tonight they're also asking
community members to support them by
attending this rally now you might be
able to hear it in the background but
organizers are also calling for the
landfill where the bodies of other
missing indigenous women were found for
that landfill to be shot down now
they're also calling on all levels of
government to bring to take more action
meaningful action to protect indigenous
women and girls including implement
seeing the recommendations in the
National inquiry into missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls
mithu Rosanna Hempel in Winnipeg thanks
Pope Francis has missed a major easter
event after being hospitalized for
bronchitis last week the pontiff did not
preside over the Good Friday way of the
Cross celebration at the Coliseum the
Vatican blames Rome's cold weather the
pope though did attend the evening
prayer service at St Peter's Basilica he
still set to attend Mass tomorrow and
Easter Sunday
the rare overlap of Easter Passover and
Ramadan is fueling tensions in the
Middle East tonight police in Tel Aviv
say a car rammed into a group of people
near a popular Seaside Park killing a
30-year-old man the Israeli government
is calling it a terror attack the
escalation of violence comes after
Israeli forces stormed the Al-Aqsa
mosque in occupied East Jerusalem this
week Crystal gomancing Reports
[Music]
prayers in peace but the situation is
still tense and violent
Before Sunrise Rockets streaked across
the sky incoming attacks mostly
intercepted by Israel's defense system
are said to be the work of Hamas which
controls some territory in the West Bank
[Music]
outgoing Rockets made landfall
Israel says it hit Hamas territories in
Lebanon and Gaza simultaneously The
Barrage into Gaza is believed to be the
largest since August
this man says we heard three or four
huge explosions not normal ones I
carried my daughter and started running
it's just one of the brutal scenes
that's emerged since Israeli forces
first stormed the al-axis Moss Tuesday
night beating worshipers
[Music]
near an Israeli settlement in the
occupied West Bank a bullet riddled car
two Israeli women were killed one was
injured
spokesperson praised the shooters but
did not take responsibility Hamas
considered a terror group
internationally is not the only concern
in the region the Lion's Den a newer
Grassroots cell made up of mostly young
Palestinian men is also active Israeli
forces meanwhile are adding troops in
the north and south
on Thursday more than 30 Rockets were
fired from Lebanon into Israel a blitz
that has not occurred since 2006.
the violence appears to have unified
prime minister Benjamin netanyahu's
government he visited the deadly
shooting site with the defense minister
he fired for criticizing his judicial
reforms just last month he says his goal
is to ensure the safety and security of
his community
Crystal gemancing Global News London
the American journalist detained by
Russian authorities last week on
allegations of spying has now been
formally charged according to Russian
State media Wall Street Journal reporter
Evan gershkovich is being charged with
Espionage officially starting a criminal
investigation he's accused of trying to
obtain classified information on a
Russian weapons Factory both gershkovich
and the journal deny those claims his
arrest is being internationally
condemned as an attack by Moscow on
press freedoms
sounding the alarm about a new scam
coming up how criminals are going after
grocery shoppers
federal tax workers have voted
overwhelmingly in favor of strike action
ahead of mediation talks later this
month the unions representing some 35
000 employees say their members have
been without a contract for more than a
year the workers will be in a legal
strike position next Friday with the
final round of bargaining not scheduled
until April 17th a strike has the
potential to disrupt tax filings across
the country which for many Canadians
must be submitted by May 1st
when this year's federal budget was
released part of the government's
Financial Vision was offering a
so-called grocery rebate to help
low-income Canadians but just a week and
a half later fraudsters are already
finding ways to take advantage tariya
isri explains how criminals are using a
phishing scam to Target struggling
Canadians and how people can avoid
getting duped
every time the phone rings pings or
vibrates Canadians are growing
increasingly suspicious about who's on
the other end how often do you get scam
text messages or phone calls every day
all the time so you get several a day
there's a new scam to be on the lookout
for fraudsters are going after people
already struggling that is what this
budget invests in the signature item in
this year's federal budget is the
so-called grocery rebate a one-time
payment of 234 dollars to single
Canadians
467 dollars for families with children
and 225 dollars for seniors but almost
as soon as it came out criminals tried
to cash in sending Canadians this text
message with a phony link to claim 247
masquerading as the one-time grocery
rebate folks that perpetrate this kind
of fraud on individuals they they
typically follow the headlines very
closely they're all versions of a
phishing scam a way to trick you into
giving away personal and financial
information to sum the grocery rebate
scam is easy to spot I'm just very aware
of any kind of text messages sent so I
wouldn't trust that at all anyway you do
would you trust that no I would not
trust that they're easy to fall for some
of them are very good cyber Security
Experts warn seniors are especially
vulnerable there are ways to protect
yourself never follow links that just
came unsolicited in a text message also
monitor your bank accounts
update passwords regularly and use
multi-factor authentication two or more
ways to verify your identity before you
get into your account while personal
responsibility is crucial cyber security
experts say It's Not the Only Solution
they believe Canadian laws and
protections need to be updated for the
21st century let's create a more secure
way of of proving who you are than just
a 50 75 year old SIN number that's
pretty easy to steal the push to do more
to protect Canadians from con artists
who are trying to profit off hard
Economic Times teria Israeli Global News
Ottawa
home ownership Out Of Reach ahead why
some Canadians say they're stuck renting
even as home prices Trend down
[Music]
for so many Canadians owning a home is
Out Of Reach especially given the cost
of living but there are signs the market
is rebounding despite High interest
rates in Toronto new data shows home
sales in that City jumped 44 in March
compared to February the average price
of a home Rose two but is still down
about 15 percent from a year ago in
Vancouver home sales in March were also
much lower than the same time last year
but sales are up from February tonight
Anne gaviola looks at how the Market's
trending
you could call it a housing conundrum
home prices are down nearly 20 percent
from the highs of early 2022 but a
majority of people hoping to break into
the market still find it unaffordable
according to new polling by ipsos
exclusively for Global News despite the
fact that we've had a softening of
housing prices over the last year and
that interest rate increases have
leveled and are perhaps going to be
hopefully going down soon
attitudes have not changed among those
looking to buy 71 say they're sidelined
because of high interest rates less than
a third say now is a good time to buy
and despite the fact that 76 percent say
home ownership is a good investment 63
percent of those not already in the
market have given up on ever owning a
home do you think you'll ever be able to
buy a house
uh no I think going forward it will be
difficult for me but the way that the
you know
economy is and the money I make I doubt
it a growing number of renters nearly 70
percent now believe home ownership is
only for the rich is it your goal to
someday own a home yeah
it's not going really well but as one
can dream I guess it makes you even more
frustrated and perhaps even angry at
those who do have a home because there's
a growing divide in this country and
it's not necessarily men or women or
albertans versus quebecers it's whether
you own a home or not a widening gap
between the housing halves and have-nots
and gaviola Global News Toronto
Thursday was the anniversary of the
Humboldt Broncos bus crash that killed
16 people many of them young members of
a Saskatchewan hockey team but today is
also important for an inspiring movement
created out of that tragedy April 7th is
green shirt day aimed at raising
awareness for organ donor registration
it was first started to honor
21-year-old Broncos player Logan boulay
who died a day after the crash from his
wishes to be an organ donor he was able
to save others in the weeks after the
tragedy about 150 000 Canadians signed
up to be organ donors
Dire Wolf Discovery next the
significance of a popular Ice Age
Predator found in what's now Canada
there's been lots of Easter excitement
for animals at the Zeta cell zoo in
London endangered Sumatran Tigers
meerkats and squirrel monkeys are
getting to play with eggs the Tigers
tossed around giant cardboard cutouts
the meerkats searched among rocks and
sand and the squirrel monkeys enjoyed
colorful eggs dangling in the trees Zoo
staff say the activity is not only fun
to watch it also helps animals practice
their natural foraging and hunting
skills
Southern Alberta already has a
reputation for its Rich prehistoric
history with one of the world's largest
deposits of dinosaur bones but a new
discovery suggests it was home to a
fierce Ice Age Predator one that might
be familiar to Game of Thrones fans
researchers now say the Dire Wolf roamed
the area 50 000 years ago Heather urac's
West has more on how it survived so far
north when most of the region was
covered in ice
it's a direwolf on HBO's Game of Thrones
dire wolves were magical creatures of
the North
turns out these beasts were once
creatures of the Canadian North as well
you can picture a gray wolf in your head
but picture it being supersized about
the size of a Saint Bernard dog that's
what a direwolf would have looked like
and I'll work on taking the spot just to
the west of you evidence of the Dire
Wolf was first discovered decades ago in
this area near Medicine Hat Alberta a
site where the remains of Ice Age
mammals like saber-toothed tigers have
also been found but for the direwolf
researchers had very little to go on
basically what they found was a crushed
lower jaw of a wolf and as you can
imagine when you're buried under Rock
for thousands of years you get a little
bit crushed so it's covered in cracks
some of the teeth are missing things
like that technology finally helped
mathematically confirm that the Jawbone
did in fact belong to a Dire Wolf making
this the northernmost confirmed example
of the species ever found if we didn't
know that the direwolf was here in
Alberta at this time we wouldn't know
you know which Predators were preying on
the large herbivores that existed in the
area like horses and camels and bison
and mammoths when it comes to Canada's
Ice Age history there is still so much
to explore but Reynolds believes the
answers lie in the Southern Alberta
formations here far from the fictional
world of Westeros the place where the
real direwolves called home Heather
urich's West Global News Calgary
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm nitu garcha tonight
here Canada is Kingston Ontario City
Hall lit up at night we love seeing your
Canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
Fara Nasser will be back at the anchor
desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you